traffic cameras on a nearby Motorway
capture a massive explosion as the two
trains Collide the fireball reduced the
passenger Train's engine and two front
cars to strips of metal
the freight trains forward engine was
hoisted from the track
rescue workers who were there moments
after the crash described the scene what
we saw was without precedent burned
remains a stench in the air the smell of
burning plastic shapeless sheet metal
fire people in pain it was a living hell
it still is
I just wish strength to the people
who've lost loved ones and hope the
injured can go home fully recovered at
Larissa General Hospital on Thursday
dozens of relatives many of them parents
of young people coming home from a
three-day weekend were trying to match
their DNA to that of body parts and
sorrow mixed with anger was palpable
across this city
three weeks ago the railway Workers
Union issued a public complaint
demanding investment in personnel and
automated signaling equipment saying a
major accident was only a question of
time and they weren't the first last
year the Hellenic Railways Chief safety
officer resigned over a lack of safety
procedures larisa's station master has
been charged with manslaughter by
negligence for allowing the passenger
train to travel North on a southbound
track but people here say he is not the
only one to blame
we can't scapegoat the station master or
anyone else responsibilities must be
meted out to all those who are really to
blame anyone who has a share of the
blame must pay his share because it
seems that the responsibilities go
beyond the station Master at least
according to the unions
the Prime Minister has promised Clarity
on what went wrong with Greece's rail
infrastructure which is a state
responsibility that could bring great
political cost but people want answers